think the challenge for kevin stefanski
with a few extra days to get ready for
washington is going to be to have that
game plan ready to pivot to pass the
ball if they are stacking the box to
take away chubb and hunt not that it
matters because i feel like they already
are trying to take away the run but hunt
and chubb are so good you can't take
away the run they're going to get their
yards that offensive line getting it
done for the browns but but for the
browns
if they can just continue to grow that
passing game and you you hit the nail on
the head with otto beckham jr and this
is why i've said all week they should
trade him and i still believe they
should trade him i'm not going to change
that opinion simply because he caught a
touchdown pass last night and caught
three other passes
he does not fit with that team
especially if the answer is to run the
ball and run the ball and run the ball
some more the good news for the browns
is if he has performances like last
night he actually has trade value
the the uh the monday after the original
game of the season you look at odell
beckham jr and say why would anyone want
him the friday after the second game you
say yeah okay there's something there if
they end up deciding to move on from him
and peter i think that that you know you
you raised this point he's not going to
be happy if they run the ball this much
well then now's the time to sell for
whatever you can get for odell beckham
jr and i don't feel any differently
about that simply because he had a a
good game not a great game last night
what do you really think the market
value is right now for odell beckham jr
well here's the thing who would have
thought last year the patriots would
give up a second round pick for muhammad
sunu
and the 49ers would give up a third
round pick for emmanuel sanders both of
whom just finished the season with those
teams sanders left in free agency sunu
got cut
so i don't know there was a report from
wfan in the off-season that i think the
vikings and the giants supposedly
talking about a second-rounder for
beckham i i think a second-rounder would
make sense a lot of it depends upon what
he does between now and whenever that
contending team as it approaches the
trade deadline decides let's make the
move but i think at a minimum a second
rounder don't you
well
i'm not that
concerned about what what the
compensation is
i wonder
how many teams
want that anchor of a contract
you know how many teams are going to
take on a a huge payday
you know that that he that he basically
uh will carry with him knowing knowing
that he's not necessarily going to be
happy and he's not going to be content
so that's the big question to me
you know not that okay a two way
you know look right now to me
if
new england could solve its receiver
problems uh by waving at the magic wand
of of a second round draft choice i'm i
bet that bill belichick would do it
the patriots are going to have major
major problems with their receiver core
this year in my opinion the exact same
as they had last year
because they're the same guys minus
muhammad sunu
so
so i i think i think belichick would
would like the player would he like the
anchor
of
uh on the salary cap that odell beckham
brings
well the the financial aspect of it
going in is not as significant as it as
you would think he's got a 14 million
salary this year 15.5 million dollar
compensation package next year 14.75
each of the final two years of the deal
but the thing is at some point he's
going to want a new contract when you
see what deandre hopkins is getting when
you see what julio jones is getting if
he goes somewhere and he's effective
he's going to want to rip up that deal
and replace it with another one so
that's a separate issue but i think the
patriots make the most sense for him a
lot of teams would not be able to absorb
odo beckham jr and get him to comply
with the way they do things because
there's that constant expectation you're
going to get him the ball and i'm a firm
believer in the quarterback throwing to
the guy who's open the hell with trying
to get the ball to a certain player that
just drags down your offense and it
creates tension and frustration and
that's been one of the problems in
cleveland and it's not going away just
because they won last night because any
time they lose that's going to be item
number one did you get the ball enough
to odell beckham jr but he's craved this
idea of going to new england now once he
gets there if he gets there he may feel
differently about the patriot way and
what it what it does to you to break you
down to get you to comply to get you to
submit to get you to quit thinking about
your own individual accomplishments but
i feel like that's what he needs i think
he needs someone who's going to put it
to him straight who who has the
authority to to get him to forget about
how many catches he has and just focus
on winning he seems to be focused on
winning and
you know when i looked at the patriots
dolphins game from last week there was a
stretch early in the third quarter where
there were a lot of guys open kind of in
the underneath zones that's the area
where if you hit beckham in stride he's
gone
so you you combined cam newton and otto
beckham jr that offense could be scary
and the thing we know about bill
belichick you never know what the hell
he's gonna do until he does it so would
it surprise either of us if all of a
sudden between now and the tuesday after
week eight odell beckham jr becomes a
patriot it wouldn't surprise me and i
think it's the the move that makes the
most sense to get the most out of
beckham to help the browns and to help
the patriots
yeah i i think they're the most logical
team without any question i think
uh and i think bill belichick definitely
is going to be able to have the juice to
do it that especially
if they are
in a good place at that point if there
are a couple games over 500 something
like that and it looks like this
division easily could be theirs
then it wouldn't surprise me at all if
they did that as you say
i just wonder whether uh whether bill
belichick is going to think he's worth
it or
would bill belichick say
give me the steadier alan robinson and
we will pay for him and we'll give him a
new contract because the one thing about
alan robinson that differs
you know with uh you know differs from
odell beckham jr
is that alan robinson for the vast
majority of his career you've never
heard a word out of him
you know and and he's more of a
belichick guy i think but again i agree
with you i think that if any team in the
nfl makes sense
for beckham it's new england
and let's hear from baker mayfield
regarding what happened with odell
beckham jr last night the relationship
between those guys so critical let's
listen to the words and study the facial
expressions of baker mayfield as he
talks about odell beckham's touchdown
from last night
what did you see on the touchdown to
odell and how nice was it to get an
explosive play with him
uh one-on-one coverage uh you know we
ran first play of the game ran a uh a
keeper to the left and did the comeback
and so kind of just
saw how the guy was playing it and he
was real aggressive all over him so we
knew that we were gonna have a shot at
that come back to it uh you know called
at the right time and he ran a great
route
peter i saw the seinfeld tell did you
see the seinfeld tell any time you
touched your face that means the holy
spirit isn't going great he went like
that you know the higher you touch the
worse the relationship oh it's going
good yeah it's all right ah we got to
get out of here there it is there it is
it's the tell
look i i'm just i'm just kidding you
know the problem is it's never been
natural between otto beckham jr and
baker mayfield and it's funny because
earlier this week they said well it's
got to be natural and we're really
working on it no that's not how it works
it's either natural or it's not and it's
just not and that's okay
at some point
it's fine to admit that it's not working
the best teams
admit their mistakes instead of doubling
down on them and i know some browns fans
out there thinking what the hell it
you'd think we'd lost last night but
this is still something that is an
impediment to the long-term growth of
the team right am am i wrong that this
team would not be better off based on
what we saw last night to remove that
constant source of tension and stress
that comes from this compulsion to get
the ball to odell beckham jr
well
i don't know that that is there well
let's see if it's there the same this
year as it was last year because the one
thing that we don't know mike
let's say the browns go on a three-game
winning streak let's just say and i'm
not saying that they will but let's just
say they do
let's see how odell beckham if if one
game he gets two targets
and let's say this week this coming week
they beat washington by 20 he gets two
targets and they run for 190 yards
that obviously is a great game for the
cleveland browns
so if beckham is grousing about that
you know if he's clearly unhappy then
all right then let's see but i'm willing
to give him
a few weeks to see how he acts this year
and let's just see what happens but
i think they have plenty of time to make
this decision i don't think this is a
decision they have to make on september
18th
and i would give them the chance
you know for this to work this year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports